Jen what makes crime drama so popular
crime drama has been popular since the
beginning of time since Kan and abble
the very first murder so I I think I
have lots of theories on why it's so
popular I think that one theory is in
our daily lives we encounter a lot of
mystery right like I know in my life
there's a lot of unexplained things
whether it's relational things or things
for my past or questions that I have
there's just always mystery and I I
think too like we're as humans and
especially modern humans we're not very
comfortable with mystery anymore like we
want answers for everything want
everything to make sense but in real
life it doesn't there there's a lot of
mystery that we deal with in real life
and crime dramas give us the opportunity
to explore mystery and solve it so that
the end of the the day we don't have the
Myster has been solved there's that
catharsis in like I've got the answers
it was figured out um so I think that's
one huge
reason and one other reason I think
crime dramas are so popular is because I
believe we have this really
innate sense of justice and Redemption
that we're born with that like we want
to see Justice we want things to be
redeemed that are not are unfair or that
are
injust uh we want to see chaos ordered
there's a lot of Chaos in the world we
want to see we just have this innate
desire to see all of that ordered and
writed and the wrongs writed and and
Justice and we again we don't always get
to see that every day in our real lives
we live sort of sometimes in
chaotic situations or um bad things
happen that don't get always get
redeemed but in crime
dramas chaos is ordered the wrongs are
writed we get Justice we get that
redemption in that world and I think it
gives us a really great
catharsis why do you think some stories
are more popular than others I'm
thinking of like the Black Dalia things
that over time every generation seems to
be interested in yeah that's so great
such a great
question I weirdly right we have this
fash fascination with sort of very the
grotesque and the
unusual
and um the barbaric honestly I mean look
at dmer right Jeffrey dmer and now the
popularity of that whole series and the
Black Dalia is classic case of that too
um I don't know I think that's just kind
of innate too in who we are and as
humans that it's so bizarre right and
outside
of
what we know should
be um human
dignity and I guess we're kind of drawn
to that and why does that happen and why
does it happen to certain people and
what CA and the people who caused that
who are these people um sort of the
whole mystery around all of that I think
it will always
be always have that question of why
lingering over it you know why her why
that woman why in that way and who would
have done that and same with you know
any other kind of very popular sort
of uh eccentric murder I guess is a
polite way to say it what is your
favorite crime mystery story like is
there a certain show certain book I have
so
many
um okay I got to think that's a really
good question I have so
many
um I don't know that I could say like by
name what my favorite is but I'm very
interested
in
stories um that have a psychological
nature to them um that explore the
Criminal Mind I'm very interested in
historical you know things uh Crim
criminality I guess in the past criminal
nature and how it was
resolved in in history in like 100 years
plus ago
um
I like anybody I like I just I have a
fascination with these serial killers
too like what makes like mine Hunters is
one of my favorite um of of late of the
last few years books and series because
I love how it
explored the mind of the serial killer
and how that that Behavioral Science
evolved so I like that I think that's a
very
fascinating um a very fascinating aspect
of human psychology and criminality to
explore um I tend not to
like I I shouldn't say like I tend not
to absorb or consume a lot of like cozy
mystery or lighter I don't know what
that says about me I love comedy but not
not when it pertains to criminality I
guess I don't know
um yeah let's I'm trying to think what
do I watch what do I read
um but I do like I do like the Corky
like um there was a series while back
Veronica Mars I think that was a lot of
fun and I think that coming of age and
kind of teen crime solving is fun um
Pushing Daisies was very fun I I like I
think just because it was in a very
quirky world it was more about the
quirkiness of the world and the
characters more so than the crimes the
nature of the
crimes do you think we as viewers want
to see um a show that surprises us or
read a book that surprises us or do we
as the viewer or the reader want to be
two steps
ahead I think it depends on what kind of
person you
are
uh I I think it has a lot to do with
yeah with personality type and and what
some people are big puzzle solvers right
and they want to be two steps two steps
ahead and some people want to go for the
ride and just be sort of carried along
and and really get into the world and
the characters and sort of be surprised
and see what happens I really think it
completely depends on your personality
so I'm thinking back to like uh Unsolved
Mysteries yeah that it was the kind of
show that they would just give you
little vignettes or little Snippets of a
story but it had you thinking like who
and what and would leave you with these
questions and yeah that was it was like
a puzzle that's a great way to say it
yeah exactly do you think the rise in uh
like crime podcast through crime
podcasts or uh
shows in some sense can hurt the
families of the victims or is it in in a
sense helpful because information can be
crowdsourced and it could lead to
solving the crime right um it's always a
fine line I know that investigators are
always kind of walking that fine line um
of how much to reveal and how much the
public gets to know or doesn't get to
know
[Music]
um
I I never thought about that question
actually
um I believe that criminal science and
forensics
are
art as well as
science so it's a constantly
evolving art form SL science techniques
right so it's kind of like medicine
medicine today looks very different than
it did 100 years ago it's a constantly
evolving science it's also an art um my
dad who's a physician always used to say
look medicine is more art sometimes than
science because we're con everybody's
body is different and and medicines
react differently and certain treatments
will react differently sometimes
depending on the person and I think it's
kind of that way Case by case um with
these crime podcasts and all the crime
cases that are being sort of shown into
the light through film TV podcasts all
of this a lot of these are cold cases
things that happen have happened a while
ago and so when you look at perhaps how
they were solved 5 10 15 20 30 40 years
ago then you have to look at it under
the lens of what was Crim solving like
and what were the techniques available
at that time versus now because so you
see where I'm going with this it's like
it's very much it can be helpful
sometimes because we didn't always have
certain things then that we do now um
and I think it can be helpful because so
maybe some there are sometimes criminals
who were put away who shouldn't have
been because of certain things witness
testimonies or DNA that wasn't processed
properly or whatever the the case may be
so
um I think that if there's a legitimate
reason to bring the case to light if
there are a lot of question marks
because again it was probably you know
more an art than a science
then that's can be a good thing um for
for the justice system for the families
um E I think though either way there's
going to be how do I
say there's always going to be people
who in this process of digging up all
these cases and looking at things again
who may feel
disenfranchised or they're being wronged
all over again um that maybe they're
being
revictimized um or that are maybe V
angry because their loved ones killer
was put away and now they're digging
something up to say wait you're now
you're going to try to free them that's
a ve that can be a very
unsettling uh experience so I think that
will always be the case because you're
you're stirring up something that maybe
other people have put to
rest